this week convex on is in Belgium home
to NATO now seriously concerned by
Russian military operations in Syria my
guest is general Philip Breedlove the
Alliance's top military commander why
are the Russians running rings around
him
general Breedlove welcome to conflict
zone thanks for having me
how weak do you think NATO looks to the
Russians at the moment I don't think I
would use that term I think that when
Russia looks at the NATO nations they
see first of all solidarity I was able
to attend
well summit was pretty impressive to sit
among the 28 leaders of our nations and
listen to how quickly and how stridently
they came to their discussion of
solidarity collective defence and their
absolute commitment to that it's pretty
important but the reason I ask that
question is they march over an
international border NATO says
unacceptable they fly their planes into
the sovereign airspace of a NATO member
they give you one hour to get out of
Syrian airspace that's kicking sand in
your face isn't it so I think that
walking over the international border a
distinction has to be made of course I
do believe that Russia understands the
difference of a NATO border but clear
brain was in the partnership for peace
it was still in peace yes absolutely
as to the other instances as you know
the Russian ministers have come back and
said that they're they're flying across
the Turkish border was a navigational
error these are things that we'll have
to which you don't accept which
Washington hasn't accept that's correct
that's what I hear
so in NATO as well our Secretary General
was pretty straightforward that that
seems to be a thin argument so we're
next they fly up the Thames in London or
they fly down the shells Alizee in Paris
NATO goes around calling this
unacceptable and yet there's no response
well what would you do if you were in
Moscow you do some more you'd ramp it up
wouldn't you well I think that that's
where I was in nature weak yeah I don't
think NATO is weak what I see is a
military and alliance that is standing
first of all by its value
and part of that value is having some
judgment of course our Turkish brothers
who intercepted the aircraft in southern
Turkey could have made a different
choice but they chose a voice of reason
and they communicated across the radio
the Russian aircraft turned and returned
to Syria so I think that this is the way
we should proceed we don't have made a
choice to shoot it down they could have
they could have and standard defense
procedures would have allowed them to do
that that's correct they have announced
and as you have seen in the past there
has been shoot downs in that area what
do you think the Russians would have
done if you transgressed their border in
the same way do you think they'd have
just turned the other cheek and said oh
come back and do it another day
well first we would have to ask would
they have seen it I mean there are a lot
of places where their coverage is very
very good if they had seen it I think
they would be equally as incensed as we
were maybe a bit more than in a sense
they just shut it down a little bit I
know I'm not sure but clearly they would
have been in as incensed general the
impression seems to be that the Russians
are called literally calling the shots
at the moment they tell Washington and
they tell the coalition that they're
just putting in a few men and supplies
into Syria the next thing we know is
that they are engaged in their largest
military intervention in the Middle East
in decades in decades correct they just
didn't happen to mention it to you now
and you didn't happen to know about it
either which is also concerning isn't it
we did not have all the details that's
correct it is concerning but it's a
pattern I mean remember what we saw in
Crimea we're not there we're not there
well yes we were there remember what we
still see in the dome boss where they
continue to claim that they're not there
we all know they're there and now the
same sort of pattern a cut occurring in
Syria as I said they gave you an hour to
get out of Syrian airspace I don't think
you obliged on that occasion that's
correct but how long before the Russians
start interfering with your combat
operations their growing presence
they're growing
activity the level of activity how long
before that happens what I think it
would be it would be a guess but what as
you know at this point we have begun
bilateral talks with them to try to set
up well safety procedures so that we
don't come into contact with each other
but they're just saying by their actions
that they don't care whether you're
there or not they'll barely see you the
instructions don't issue you the orders
and you can get out of the way if you
want but otherwise they're going ahead
that doesn't sound like much in the way
of consultation no I agree with that but
what we do see what is actually
happening on the ground is they're
staying in flight patterns that take
them into areas that don't typically
come into conflict with where our
coalition is flying and when they do and
this is this could happen quite easily
it could that's something that's going
to get out of control very quickly
couldn't it well that's why we're having
these talks we're initiating these
safety procedures so that it doesn't but
that were talks in September when they
just said they were bringing in a few
men and materiel so you can't rely on
the talks can you because they're not
telling you they're not telegraphing
ahead what their actions are gonna be
clearly and what we need to do is try to
open reasonable talks that we can depend
on so where's the red line what do they
have to do for NATO to stop saying
things are unacceptable and put some
markers in the in the dust first of all
I would never use this term redline
that's I don't think that's appropriate
from a military individual you leave
that to the politicians so what I would
talk about is things in which I do
believe they understand they understand
what article 5 is they understand what
collective defence is and I think those
are appropriate things to talk about do
you think your allies understand what
article 5 is and collective defenses
because I had this discussion recently
with the former Polish foreign minister
Radek Sikorski right and he couldn't
tell me whether article 5 was a Costin
guarantee or not I can't speak for what
he thought about I think you should
refer back to what my president said at
Wales and
that is that NATO and the United States
will defend its allies he could not have
been more clear hand on heart general if
the Russians move in to Poland or the
Baltic States is does the u.s. go to war
hand on heart
if the Russians moved into those states
now they would come in contact with US
forces that are already in those very
small US forces however US forces and
yes I believe what my president said and
that is the United States and NATO u.s.
well if it happened on a an immediate
basis it is a small force but remember
also Poland has a very capable military
force when it comes to Syria Russia is
filling a vacuum isn't it that was left
by the US and the coalition forces the
failure of US efforts to arm and train
Syrian rebels this has gone very badly
there's there's there's a vacuum a clear
vacuum that they came in to fill didn't
they I think what Russia is trying to do
in in Syria I agree with what many
pundits are saying I look at it in the
following framework first and foremost
Russia wants to be seen as a mayor
player major player on the world scene
they want to be seen as an equal to
those in the West
second of all Russia desperately wants
to hang on to its ports in its airfields
in Syria third they need to prop up
Assad because he is their guarantor of
those airfields and and ports in Syria
and I do believe that the Russians
clearly want the world looking at what
they're doing here in Syria see how
we're cooperating so that the world's
not watching to what they're doing in
continuing to do in Ukraine can they
succeed where you failed I know you
spent five hundred million dollars to
train rebel forces the first batch were
kidnapped killed forced to flee the
second batch 25% of their ammunition
arrived at al-qaeda's doorstep it's been
a catastrophe hasn't it so you you're
trying to grade a larger effort by the
two incidences I would never use the
word that you used okay let me use a
word than the General Martin Dempsey the
last chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff used he said the battle was
stalemated I think he's absolutely
entitled to that opinion and I don't
necessarily disagree with him at the
time
but how does a group like Isis like Isis
or ISIL stalemate a 28-nation military
alliance led by the United States that's
quite an achievement isn't it well what
it is is you into a stalemate
what it is is an acceptance of the fact
that we are conducting a campaign that
does not involved the land elements of
that coalition and so as we try to
develop or enable land elements that are
on the ground you can understand the
conundrum but there was a promise on the
ground there was a promise from
President Obama
he said September 2014 we will degrade
and ultimately destroy ISIL through a
comprehensive and sustained
counterterrorism strategy since you said
that their numbers have doubled the
numbers of foreign fighters who've been
joining them double they're now carrying
our operations and aligned with other
groups in at least 10 countries and
areas so they're not being degraded well
astounding aren't they I think that on
the ground in the area where you discuss
just a moment ago they certainly are
being degraded think of what their size
would be without the efforts of the
coalition now as to out them spreading
in other places in the world this is
clearly an issue which the entire
western world and elements of the rest
of the world are going to have to
address because ISIL or this - this
movement is definitely growing in
different directions don't doesn't the
West the coalition NATO United States
will have a credibility problem now in
that region because the words aren't
backed up with deeds are they well what
our dress demands acid goes he stays
u.s. threatens retaliation if Syria uses
chemical
weapons there's no retaliation this was
a red line I know you don't like the
term red lines but this was the red line
which Senator John McCain said the other
day must have been written in
disappearing ink because they didn't
mean what everybody thought it meant so
I guess I would attack this from a
different way why do you think Russia is
there what do you think their impression
of what was happening to Assad in his
regime was happening I think Russia came
in because they see that the Assad
regime was under great pressure and
could have been failing so the coalition
and those that they are trying to help
to bring about a political change in
Syria was a coupling seeing its
objective in a lot of ways and I think
that's why you may have seen Russia rush
in to try to prop up their a client
state if we could go on to Ukraine
Russia in some detail you you went to
Washington in April you spoke
disturbingly about critical intelligence
that you didn't have that's correct you
told the Senate Armed Services Committee
Russian military operations in Ukraine
and the region more broadly have
underscored that there are critical gaps
in our collection and analysis some
Russian military exercises have caught
us by surprise I come back to the point
you have a intelligence machine that
costs around last time there were public
figures it hasn't been for a while
probably about 80 billion dollars a year
how do you have critical gaps where
Russia is concerned but the Eisen is you
have I think it's actually very easy to
understand remember that some use to
decades some use 18 years some use 14
years but for 14 to 20 years we've been
trying to make a partner out of Russia
and all this time trying to bring them
into a family of values and morals that
we could understand miss think so as it
turned out and so during that time we
have redirected of huge portion of our
intelligence apparatus to the threats
that we saw in Iraq in Syria in
Afghanistan and so this machine that you
talk about
the past two decades has been redirected
and now what I think you see we see now
a Russia that has decided that forces
back on the table that they will use
force to change internationally
recognized borders they still occupy the
Ukrainian Peninsula of Crimea their
forces are still in door box and they're
not leaving and so well let me finish my
thought so the bottom line is for almost
two decades we've redirected that
intelligence apparatus to the other
counterterrorism threats and now we have
to make decisions to bring back the
focus on Russia that is proving to not
hold to those standards and morals and
values that the rest of the world share
but here's the worrying thing general if
you're not even getting reliable
intelligence about Russia's military
exercises
what possible chance do you have of
getting a warning of any real attack
we've been talking about the exercises
that you didn't see coming right this is
a great conversation in fact it's a
conversation that I have often now among
our NATO allies that we need to refocus
our intelligence in order to develop
these indications and warnings the basis
for doing so last year it wasn't
refocused you weren't seeing even the
exercises taking place certainly we had
a two billion dollar machine and they
are not seeing the gaps if you don't see
them who can eighty billion dollar
machine remember that was refocused to a
different part of the world but it's got
a lot of arms and entrails hasn't it it
does and so now what we're having to do
is reestablish that Intel baseline that
allows us to understand when we see a
spike an indication and warning so that
we can do just what you talked about
there's a general acceptance not only
that Russia has changed its views and
its behavior over time but that it now
represents an existential threat a
number of your colleagues have said this
we had general se-jin bradshaw deputy
commander of nato forces in europe so
tensions with Russia could blow up into
an all-out conflict posing an
existential threat to our whole being
you stand by that I've said it myself
your homework kind of left you short of
it so your intelligence capability has
chosen quite a time to go for a walk in
the park hasn't it well with this
existential threat facing NATO clearly
for all the years that we have faced a
Russia with the nuclear arsenal that it
has we've had an existential threat and
nuke in Russia and so we have kept an
intelligence focus on those strategic
forces but what you were asking me about
earlier were those operational and
tactical forces and that's where we took
that capacity and moved it to a
different place and now of course we're
refocusing how long is that going to
take how long are you gonna be blind for
I don't think nothing's moving there
things are moving very fast yeah how
long are you gonna be behind that's a
word you're using I would never use that
word either
and we are lonely is your sight going to
be inadequate it improves every day
because our intelligence community has
begun refocusing on some of these issues
did the West seep walk into a crisis
over Ukraine should they have been
avoided well certainly we didn't sleep
walk into it but I think you have the
words right because I've used them
myself some of the operational and
tactical things that we saw surprised us
but what I think is remember the
framework under which Crimea first
started we are again now we all
understand there was a bad bump in the
system in 2008 when Russia invaded
Georgia but as we were approaching
Crimea but you forgave them for that
that's I wouldn't use that personal
pronoun of me no but the West did well
pretended to get them as if it hadn't
happened I can't speak for all the
nations of the West and I can't even
speak for the political leadership of
NATO but I noticed you don't quarrel
with my characterize it clearly we as
military men and women saw a military
incursion into Georgia and for a lot of
reasons which I think we saw the same
thing in Ukraine to keep them from
entering
relationships with the West you want to
put more arms into Ukraine no I what I
have said in the past is that we should
not take this consideration off of the
plate in other words as we approach
Ukraine we should use all our options
just like Russia is using all of its
options you know the model that military
people use diplomatic informational
military economic all for bring about
being brought to bear on Ukraine by
Russia so we should keep all four on our
plate but you know you did say that but
you also said inaction is also in action
that's very Russians will react to that
as well that's correct so what are we
saying no you're coming down on the side
of putting more arms into crime I say we
should not take any options off of the
plate they should all be considered do
you think they'll listen to you if you
don't well that way let's look what's
happened in the last few days we've had
a good Normandy format which seems to be
having some effect and so let's give
this Normandy format being the meetings
between Hollande miracle and poroshenko
and and Russia and Putin this format has
yielded some good results in the last
few days we need to see how that works
at the same time as they're carving out
possibly an exclusion zone in the
eastern Mediterranean okay I'm telling
you and transgressing NATO airspace and
telling you to get out of Syria skies
no I think these a good discussion no I
love your the way you connect these
because I believe the world needs to see
these connections but as it relates to
Ukraine we've seen some progress and I
think we need to allow that progress
hopefully to continue but what we
realize is Joy's here no no here's where
I'm trying to get if Russia wants to
enter the responsible world of actors in
Syria then let's see continued
responsible actions in Ukraine remember
that Minsk points to reestablishing the
international border of Ukraine Russia
has moved an immense amount of equipment
into Ukraine over 1,500 pieces of
armored gear etc etcetera
it will take months for Russia to get
all of this
here kit and capability out of Ukraine
so let's see some demonstrated good
action as they start to remove that from
Ukraine one of the things you've been
trying to do in Europe and other places
is to reassure your allies we spoke a
little bit about Article five earlier
perhaps the thing that undercuts your
assurances most is the recent some of
the recent war games you've been playing
at the Kremlin at the Pentagon rather to
simulate the Russian invasion of Estonia
and Latvia since 2014 these tabletop
exercises war games all ended one way
didn't they NATO is unable to defend the
Baltics so being the result out of all
of them hasn't it I will tell you the
result that I saw out of all these
exercises and tabletop exercises we've
done is that we've we've refocused our
political decision makers and our senior
most military decision makers of the
speed in the gravity of the decisions
they're going to have to make remember
we spent almost two decades hugging the
bear now we need to be able to react to
a revanchist Russia that puts force back
on the table so what I've seen out of
these exercises is a refocus on the
decisions and the speed of decisions
that we're gonna have to make in order
to don't quarrel with it with the
results the results are that you at that
moment you cannot defend there are lots
of results but Davidoff manic who as you
know until i was head of force planning
pentagon he said
we played the game sixteen different
times with eight different teams always
the same conclusion nato is unable to
defend the Baltics I know Dave and Davis
he does good work and he is a he has
entitled to his opinions but I think
that what I pointed to before these
games point to the fact that to succeed
we have to make decisions at speed in
fact the real game-changing decisions
are made ahead of time to deter as
opposed to afterwards when we get to
more kinetic operations but if you if
you can't defend the Baltics what's the
point of having a spearhead force of
five thousand people which the Europeans
are pretty
to set up anyway nothing you said those
words
I did not know quarreling with them I
cannot I will not say that we cannot do
what you said we we this is our central
theme here at Allied command operations
supreme headquarters Allied powers
Europe is defending all of our allies
not just the Baltics even if on paper
and in the tabletop exercises you can't
at the moment do that given the right
decisions at speed we can do it general
you were in Afghanistan last month
almost a year since NATO ended its
combat I'm their office there it was the
end of the bloodiest year of the entire
war and is still going and the first n
was on its own literally yeah and the
first year since 2001 now that the
Taliban have actually seized the city
Kunduz in the north the departure plans
should be revised and shouldn't they
well god leave them in the middle of the
the worst period of conflict in 13 years
can you I think many of our military
leadership and you've heard general
Campbell are resolute support and our
American commander in Afghanistan
recommend that we should have a
different departure schedule that we
should consider that the changes and
troop levels and capabilities should be
conditioned based I know that he has
delivered his recommendations to the
command chain as have general Austin and
I and our separate command chains and
we'll see where these makers change
change the schedule changes in you we
should allow our commanders to see those
recommendations before we share them
publicly but yes we are talking about
conditions based change to our force and
capability levels would you also support
an international investigation into the
attack on the hospital absolutely
windows absolutely in fact that led to
the death of 22 people staff and
patients yep I think
that there are three now ongoing that I
know of at an international independent
investigation I think they're very
important because the story's changed I
think that our Secretary of Defense has
been very very clear on this that we
support getting to the problem what
happened how it happened and have a full
open and transparent investigation and
so we support the using a fact-finding
body that was set up under the Geneva
Conventions which is now what met some
some frontier talking about I think this
is their absolute right to ask for this
investigation and you'd support them we
will support it if what you we're gonna
support absolutely general Breedlove
thanks very much for being on conflict
zone yeah thank you
you